تقع في الجزء الشمالي الغربي من
المملكة ، تعد العلا واحدة من أقدم
المدن في شبه الجزيرة العربية التي
يعود تاريخها إلى القرن الثاني عشر ، كما أنها
موطن أول موقع للتراث العالمي لليونسكو في المملكة العربية السعودية
، وقد أصبحت
وجهة ساخنة للمسافرين
في المملكة العربية السعودية.  كانت البلاد
مغلقة نسبيًا خلال المائة عام الماضية ، وفي
العامين الماضيين ، انفتحت المملكة العربية السعودية
على السياحة ، وكجزء من استراتيجية رؤية
2030 ، يريدون نوعًا من
تبني السياحة باعتبارها ركيزة من ركائز
الاقتصاد وجلبوا أفرادًا
مثلي  الذين لديهم 30 عامًا من
الخبرة وقالوا ساعدونا في إنشاء نظام
بيئي سياحي يساعدنا في تطوير
صناعة السياحة في المملكة العربية السعودية وفي
العلا نحن على استعداد للذهاب لأن لدينا
جميع الأصول الطبيعية المذهلة التي
يسهل بيعها بشكل جيد إنها عملية بيع سهلة  لكن
علينا أن نبني الفنادق التي يجب أن
نبني بها المطاعم والمتاحف
وغيرها من عوامل الجذب التي هي
السوق المستهدف الآن لأن الإدراك هو
المفتاح ويتم تقطيعه بعيدًا
من حيث ما يعتقده الناس في المملكة
العربية السعودية وليس شيئًا
يمكنك الابتعاد عنه بسهولة عليك
مواجهته وجهاً لوجه ،
أعتقد أن جمهورنا المستهدف هو
المسافرين الأثرياء الذين يريدون أن يكونوا أول من
يختبر وجهة غير معروفة
فهم مقدامون  المسافرون والمسافرون
الذين يرغبون في الذهاب ويقولون إنني كنت أول
من زار هذا المكان الرائع حتى يتمكنوا من
إخبار أصدقائهم بإخبار عائلاتهم
أنه يمكنهم التباهي به وكذلك
الأفراد الذين لديهم فضول ويريدون
التعرف على آلاف السنين من
الحضارات وغير المعروفة
الحضارات وتفهم حقًا
تأثيرها على المجتمع المحلي وعلى
المملكة العربية السعودية والشرق الأوسط
بشكل عام ، ولذا فإننا نرى
اهتمامات قوية منك تعرف
أن أسواقنا المصدر حددنا تسعة
ملايين زائر محتمل يرغبون في
القدوم و  تجربة استنادًا إلى
هذه الملفات الشخصية قليلاً ، لذا فإن ما نقوم به الآن
هو إضافة رحلات طيران من دبي ، فنحن
نضيف رحلات طيران من باريس ونضيف
اتصالاً أفضل بالطيران  tivity أنشأنا
مطارًا دوليًا بحيث
يمكن للزوار الوصول من جميع أنحاء
العالم بالطائرة حرفيًا إلى لولا
مباشرة إلى لولا منك تعرف باريس أو
لندن أو ميلان أو نأمل أن تكون الولايات المتحدة
يومًا
ما تعمل في هذه الصناعة لفترة طويلة
أنت  اعلم أن السائح بعد
تجربة معينة بشكل صحيح ، لذا فهو يريد أن
يرى أشياء جديدة ولكنه معتاد أيضًا على
الحصول على قدر معين من
الاسترخاء وهذا عادة مع
كأس من النبيذ أو كوكتيل على وجه التحديد
في السوق ، لذلك عليك  ذُكرت إذا
كنت تنظر إلى الولايات المتحدة وأوروبا ،
كيف يمكنك الالتفاف على تلك
الجوانب الثقافية والدينية عندما
تحاول استهداف السائحين ، لذا
فقد اختفت معظم القيود القديمة التي كانت سارية ، حيث
يمكن للمرأة أن ترتدي ملابس كما لو كنت
ترتدي ملابس اليوم  لا يتعين عليهم تغطية
رؤوسهم ،
يمكنك ارتداء البيكيني في المسبح في
الموائل التي تقوم بها النساء الآن ، لذا فإن
التغيير الذي يحدث في هذا البلد
من المملكة العربية السعودية يعد دراماتيكيًا إلى حد ما
تتغير العقلية أكثر من أي شيء آخر في
النهاية ، أعتقد أن هذا خيار
قلته أنه غير متوفر اليوم ، لكن كما هو
الحال في دبي ، بدأ ببطء
خطوة بخطوة وأعتقد أنك تعرف
على الطريق قد يكون فرصة محتملة